- You know, they did it again.
I mean, I actually think that perhaps
the second season is
stronger than the first.
(upbeat bass guitar music)
When I first got the script,
I threw it in the bin.
Which is true.
I read some of it and I thought,
this is too broad for me.
And then, my boyfriend who's a writer,
read it and said, you have to do this.
It's so funny, just read it again,
read it again, read it again.
And I did, and I couldn't put it down.
Maybe I was in a bad mood, (she laughs)
I don't know what it was.
You know, it was clear in the first season
how bold and brave the writers are.
There are so many predictable ways
that the storylines could go,
and gratefully, consistently,
pleasantly surprised.
I definitely feel like
a proud mum sometimes
when observing
Asa and Ncuti.
I'm constantly surprised how
mature their choices are.
When you're talking about acting,
and certainly, their teenage
years are closer to hand
than they are for me, for instance,
where I can barely remember
whether I even had a sex ed class or,
who my first snog was.
It is interesting that they are so able
to give themselves permission, I guess,
to go back and to re-experience
some of the horrendous
and tumultuous aspects
of their teenage years.
And I remember thinking that
when I was watching the first season
and watching Asa's work and thinking,
you know, he's really properly good,
there's nothing predictable
in his responses to things.
Jean and Otis, from the very beginning,
felt like the least complicated
and difficult element of it.
We immediately fell into a rhythm
and a tone, it just felt very natural
and effortless from the beginning.
Yeah, they're all properly good.
As an ancient adult, it was hard for me
to really discern what
that reaction was gonna be.
And I've been shocked before by successes
of things that I've done.
Mostly in the opposite
direction! (she laughs)
But it was hard for me to
judge whether it would be got.
Whether people would get it.
Whether the fact that
it was both seemingly
British and American,
that is was in the past
and in the present, and
sometimes even in the future.
Well, there's certainly a sense
when going into a second season,
knowing that a fan base has
properly enjoyed something.
That one can imagine what
the reaction might be
to certain things that happen.
And you know even in the reading of it,
when you're sitting round the table read
and when you're reading
it for the first time,
you think, oh my God,
they're gonna love this!
Or whatever, and then
so in the doing of it,
it's a lot of fun to be
able to play with that
and to stretch it to its extremes.
Knowing that you're held in that place
by a sense of love and appreciation.
I think a show like this
is extraordinarily helpful
in different countries,
in different cultures,
in different neighborhoods
even, in different religions,
in different emotional relationships.
One of the extraordinary things
that the show does is it
shows that whoever you are,
and whatever your feelings
or thoughts or proclivities,
or taste or sexual preference,
whoever you claim you are
and what feels comfortable is okay.
So the fact that there's a place
where there is such diverse representation
and that there is, even
though there is conflict
and there is pain and there is fear
and there is lack of communication,
that somehow that's part of the story,
that is basically deals with everything.
To show youngsters that
everybody goes through that.
Everybody around the
world, to some degree,
will go through the same feelings
and the same struggles
and the same confusion
and the same fear, and the same shame
and the same guilt.
And to see, to watch,
and to feel represented
and to feel recognized and heard,
and to feel that you're not alone,
I think is one of the most valuable things
anyone can give anybody else.
(upbeat electronic music)